hi guys I'm Greg I'm Greg we're going to
watch the trailer for the superstar
comedian Oh a man who has never had a
flop in his life who is constantly
breaking box office records Will
Ferrell's the house Charlie home man I
didn't even know this movie existed
until today most people don't know when
a Will Ferrell movie exists until they
see a trailer again probably no I don't
okay thank you bother you I say we say
no today I want my baby they're stupid
[Music]
glad you came a dad I made a choice does
it support my daughter's dream you don't
have an update yeah here we have four
hundred and one thousand dollars
you missed it that says you have a 401k
account and Alex thinks we can install
tuition and we can't
really that's what Karen to do because
otherwise the kids are going to realize
it we I have a way for you guys to make
four years tuition in one month
underground convenient it is now you're
40 years old and you go to jail for 20
years how old are you when you get out
no how do you want to subscribe there's
a figure day we've got a nail salon
massages you're never going to believe
what's in this next room in a strip club
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she can't go to college from use work to
a life of crime
[Music]
for the message of the arrow casino you
thinking akiza what are you gonna do
anyway your friend Jason Mantzoukas guys
bigger activism Andrew J Cohen
she's a forgotten town brother not as an
H his first directed movies or I am oh
boy he worked on the script he wrote
neighbors
Mike and Dave need wedding day master
Pete everyone remembers that film feel
like a we just have to be r-rated
obviously it looks like it looked like a
car it didn't feature - yeah with the
whole Kenichi yeah like a Lincoln
becoming yeah yeah it's like the
bringing Vegas is your home it has to be
r-rated I like the idea of seeing Amy
Poehler and Will Ferrell the gun work
together seeing Will Ferrell Amy Poehler
play like you know the straight roles of
those rules that are like normal people
under 40s yeah who get thrust into like
situations that bring out a wild side of
them they'd be unrolled like that before
Will Ferrell just did get uh get out get
our black Wilford all these movies in
the term members will throw just to get
out at Amy Poehler in order to dammit
get how can ya stop through the
determine service translation just being
that get hard and Amy Poehler came out
with sisters so you know those are two
movies about creepy people are their
forties who are like doing things that
younger people did okay alright like
yeah hard a little bit did not switch
Bobby but I don't any that it's about
like you know like I'm a mild-mannered
guy who's drugged you to an extreme
situation that it really morphs them
over and yeah actually and that's the
thing about this trailer for me is this
trailer functions on two separate levels
and I'm just looking at the cast like
the cast really shines in this trailer I
don't laugh for a lot of trailer moments
in general especially with comedies
because it seems like he a thief full
scenes a lot for the bits that surely
work yeah so its context but but the
thing is like watching this there are a
lot of moments where I'm just like yeah
these people just the way they deliver
lines Will Ferrell Amy Poehler Jason
Mantzoukas like people in this trailer I
thought were really funny and that's
what made me want to see this cuz I feel
like we live in this weird time in this
movie especially highlights this is like
I wonder what the comedy game is like
because like these pitches are getting
weirder and weirder
in terms of specificity they're like
okay this is a character comedy vibes to
parents their kid gets in and then they
start an underground damn it again and
I'm like you just come up with this so
you could pin it unless this is based on
true stories like the concept is a
little bit like huh to me but it looks
funny so what can I tell ya like if it's
funny I'll just you know just go along
with it I don't know like a comedy
concept to me are getting a little funky
yeah yeah they're just like to stream a
hike like high concept weird lecture and
when one strange nugget of an idea like
there are a lot of these movies Center
rambling like a part like office
Christmas party or that there's another
one coming up kind of like that where's
just one specific event and we're gonna
throw wacky characters all the movie
called a smash I think or - yeah with
Amy Poehler and Goldie Hawn no Amy
Schumer Schumer man I needed to have
some caffeine today I am way off of my
meeting [ __ ] right this would be what I
feel I get the feeling this will be one
of those movies it might be a bit loose
might not always be on fire but I can I
imagine there's going to be some good
laughs yeah I think this will be fun
yeah I like all the people in it I was
oh it most Will Ferrell comedies
honestly yeah even the ones that I
acknowledge are not very good I have a
good layout elaborate yeah you could
have yeah yeah I was Will Ferrell has a
genuine and maybe for two I think like
they give something genuine to their
characters so they're in something
engaging about that you know in me
anyway like I can totally get how you
would they're not doing because there
was a time one was well pharaoh's career
where it was like she was doing like
movies
like sketch comedy movies in a way like
anchorman is like the sketch that is it
extended into a movie essentially oh and
all those sports movies yeah and all the
sports movies and now they're doing
these roles where it's like they're just
normal people who get thrust in a sketch
like situation yeah they're to hire
confident less like specific characters
and more like oh yeah yeah alright guys
well what do you think of the house
subscribe to the real rejects John Reese
jr. Twitter Instagram social media
manager of bloom house and the real
rejects and I didn't mention this video
new apartment new apartment new set
going to fit a couch in here so you're
stuck with chairs the audience art art
these chairs will get new chill we're
going to try and get some like red
chairs that look like movie shares but I
don't know no new sets coming together
creating exciter time